they're our best friends and very old
friends indeed
there's evidence that humans began to
domesticate dogs some 30
000 years ago as long before we tamed
the horse
or started keeping livestock
and this is the nose that always knows
a dog's sense of smell is about a
million times better
than that of humans dogs also inhale up
to 300 times per minute in short breaths
that means their olfactory cells are
constantly supplied with new odor
particles
and it's because of that amazing organ
that dogs are being brought into the
front line
in the fight against coronavirus
[Music]
welcome to this dw covet 19 special i'm
rob watts in berlin it's great to have
you with us
we know that testing is crucial to
trying to control
coronavirus millions of people the world
over have already received a swab to the
mouth
or nose in the name of stopping its
spread
but researchers in finland are trying a
new way of sniffing out coveted 19.
for a treat preferably cat food
this snout can be programmed to find
just about anything
mold bed bugs cancer now it could change
the course of coronavirus detection
meet cursi rescued from being euthanized
as a puppy in spain
he's returned that favor for years
sniffing out
deadly disease for the wise nose smell
detection association in finland
as covid19 began to spread cuci was
asked as an experiment
to try to detect it it took its about
seven minutes to
figure out that okay this is what they
want me to look out for
so that totally blew our minds have you
ever seen a dog be able to change
training since in seven minutes no no
no never the team quickly learned
canines can detect a covet-19 infection
even
five days before symptoms appear with
almost 100 percent
accuracy helsinki airport is hosting a
pilot project
through december that will include
cross-referencing canine results with
those from medical devices like it needs
to touch the skin itself here
it just takes a simple swab from a wrist
or neck
that's good and then and then yes
then just wait a couple of seconds a dog
can tell immediately if a person has
contracted coronavirus
so i received a negative result
the voluntary tests are proving popular
but no
positive signal yet from the finnish
government about scaling up the program
so since dogs are incredibly more
effective
much less expensive and far less
intrusive than other ways of detecting
the virus
why aren't public authorities everywhere
rushing to use their noses
instead of hours we found one who is
timo arankuta is deputy mayor of vanta
the site of the airport
i considered it in two minutes it took
me two minutes
arun kita's budget covers the free tests
offered to all arriving passengers
he allocated 330 000 euros total to the
four-month dog study
meanwhile he expects it will cost up to
three million euros
per month for the medical option the
nasal swab
it's quite expensive operation of course
and the docs are like 75
000 now a month arun kuta says the data
from this study should help bring in
federal funds for expansion of canine
testing
as well as legal adjustments to upgrade
the virus sniffing dogs authority
to that of their counterparts working in
customs we can have like
multi-dogs which have like they can
smell
horses and they can smell and go with
both
anaheim bjorkman is thinking far beyond
airports
we could uh train dogs with the same
samples with the same trainers
to open up
you know the the concert halls or
or big fares or go to
big working places hospitals
elderly homes football matches whatever
both hyun bjorkman and bobby linen warn
if finland doesn't harness the potential
of the dog program itself
they'll unleash it elsewhere we can move
because chrissy loves
warm weather she says health authorities
from all over the world
want to learn what these noses know
well i'm delighted to say we can speak
to professor holger falk who is chair of
the small animals department
at the university of veterinary medicine
hannover
thanks a lot for joining us can you just
explain to us what exactly it is that
the dogs
are smelling during these tests
yeah hello um and thank you for the
question uh it's quite interesting
um i mean at the end of the day we don't
know because the virus doesn't smell
but we do know that the virus needs a
cell and they hijack that cell
and then they change the metabolism in
the cell and that actually
is something what the dog can smell
so how can we be confident that what
they are detecting
is coronavirus
so um that's a very good question to ask
um what we have done
in our study is that we compared uh
people who had an
infection with coronavirus and actually
have clinical signs so where covered 19
patients
compared to a control group and those
in those groups we were able to find
a difference with a 94 hit rate
saying this what we didn't have in that
group was people who had for example
influenza virus because at that time
when we did the study
there was no influenza season so that's
what we are doing at the moment to see
how good is the dog also to able to
discriminate against
other viruses like influenza and
or also other coronary viruses the
stakes are obviously pretty high
if the test comes back and the the the
result is
is wrong do we know how the reliability
compares with more conventional
coronavirus testing
yeah it's it's it's quite it's quite
comparable uh i
mean you you should never forget that
the dog will never replace
a pcr test so it's it's just a very fast
screening mechanism and
i think you were at helsinki airport
where you could see how fast these
thoughts were actually able to sniff
out the people um so when you look at
the pure facts then you have a 96
percent
specificity and an 83 sensitivity
um so it's probably more comparable to
the antigen
tests which are out there um and then
obviously for us the gold standard test
was the pcr test so all our patients
were confirmed with the pcr
result so if we were to
roll this out further maybe nationwide
worldwide
indeed would we be able to train enough
dogs
to detect coronavirus to actually carry
that out
i think you know one of the the
challenges we are facing
is um that we often simplify our world
too much and what i mean with that is i
think you need to have different test
scenarios for different circumstances
if you run a workplace i mean you now
saw it at
a at an airport uh those sniper dots but
if you work in
uh if you have a workplace even a
hospital right one of the things you
don't have is
time so until you get your pcr test
results back it takes at least a day
um sometimes two or three days until
then you already have
quite a limited workforce so where these
antigen tests or the sniffer dogs come
in
is that you can actually do a very fast
screening test and hopefully then
get this confirmed by your pcr results
so i think that's where
i could see the dogs being able to to
fill a gap
or if you go to a concert or you go to
any other social events
you know there you could potentially see
um that they could be a reliable
screening tool
and just quickly so it's quick it's
non-invasive
and per test it could be cheaper than
conventional tests that we're seeing so
what is stopping this being
immediately rolled out
yeah that's a good question and i think
you probably have asked these
my colleagues in helsinki airport as
well i
i do probably i
i'm not i to be honest i'm not 100 sure
i think what it stops
um is that we can't believe that dogs
can
be so good in detecting medical things
we totally um believe them when they
sniff out a bomb
but we can't somehow grasp that they are
able to sniff out people who have a
certain infection
so perhaps we need to trust our
four-legged friends a bit more professor
holger falk
from the university of veterinary
medicine hanover thanks a lot for
joining us
thank you and now is the part of the
program where you get to ask the
questions to our science correspondent
derek williams
how come there are so many fewer covert
19 problems
infections and deaths in africa do
africans have better immune systems than
the rest of the world
there have been some pretty dire
predictions over the months about the
pandemic
and africa um the belief was that if the
virus has done
so much damage in in europe and the
americas
including in in many countries that have
advanced
health care facilities what would it do
to to underfunded systems in in
many african nations around one
in six people on the planet lives on the
continent so
with around 43 million covet 19 cases
worldwide so far you'd expect at least
seven million of them to have been in
africa but there have been only about
1.5 million reported
it's the same thing with deaths
statistically you'd expect around two
hundred thousand there so far
um there have been only around forty
thousand reported
why under reporting
uh could explain some of the discrepancy
but the experts think
other factors are also involved
especially the average age on the
continent which is only around
20. that's that's the lowest in the
world young people are of course
less vulnerable and there are also a lot
fewer homes
for the elderly in africa than in europe
or the us
where where facilities for seniors have
often turned into deadly hot spots
people in many african countries have
also often had
previous experience with other epidemics
and generally seem to have followed
health screening
and social distancing advice for covet
19.
high humidity might have played a
limiting role in some countries
the virus seems to spread better in
drier
cooler environments and there are indeed
some theories that many africans
might have more robust immune responses
to stars cove 2 due to previous exposure
to to other pathogens
but that hypothesis still hasn't been
backed up
by by convincing evidence